Is there any news on AJ so AJ is and son so and is has been with us for about five years. She is now going on full leave right now to deal with him.
He is doing a protocol for he's got he was diagnosed with acute myloid leukemia in just a few months ago, what he got super super super ill near death had to race to the hospital.
It was just a very crisis situation discovered the leukemia had to do some chemotherapy.
It did just really had to it was the right thing to do he was very very ill and I really do believe that the people saved his life and gets back to just our dogma of our doctrine, you could say our doctorate as far as how you should treat yourself regardless of whether your cancer or anything else is not to be dogmatic so what I mean is and I've said stated this in my book.
And and verbally said it you know a hundred times which is you know don't be take a dogmatic position in your treatment protocol so I think it's wrong if that's a if I get cancer and I'm like well I'm not doing anything natural I'm going to do everything by oncologist said is going to say that's all I'm going to do.
Well I to me I think that's foolish because you're taking this dogmatic approach against other things that could possibly help you but I also think it's just as foolish to take a dogmatic position that I would never do chemo there's no way I'm doing chemo how I understand people have experiences and they have to make decisions but I still even if you're because you're emotionally a position against you know doing chemo.
I still think you have to keep it open by that hey if God's going to lead me that way then I'm going to I'm going to do what he's going to tell me to do I'm not going to be dogmatic position that open to whatever God has for me.
But he's going to have to change my heart because he knows I don't want to do chemo or whatever that is so I just in AJ's situation it was the right thing to do.
He's got two more rounds of chemo.
He has had ups and downs to his health just he's back home right now from the hospital but he spent a week in the hospital you know last week with a serious crisis again really bad crash so keep her and AJ and
Tyler and husband and their whole family in your prayers I ask because it's just been really very difficult so she is taking a leave she is
has not been working she tried to come back part time it's just not going to work so just keep them in your prayers please.